the oldest cultures
are not human
they're from the ocean 40 million years
ago
before we walked upright before we
sparked fire
whales evolved to build relationships
in the dark
[Music]
i'm trying to start a conversation is
the
most basic way you can say it
i'm trying to put a speaker in the ocean
and talk to a whale and hope it talks
back
starting playback if this work is
successful
it will be the first experiment where we
have engaged in a dialogue with a
humpback whale
people have been studying humpback's
song for 40 50 years
and still no one really knows
why they sing
something different is happening here
the study has a high probability of
failure
we have only a month to survey at least
30 whales
it is so hard to interpret the language
of the natural world
to listen and understand
what it's saying to itself
[Music]
that is of the same proportion as
pointing all of our satellite skyward
and listening for a sign from outer
space it was pretty cool
that's pretty great we're talking back
to you
[Music]
studying whale culture might be more
about glimpsing
something of ourselves
how we can connect differently
a million years from now
you